after months of partisan fighting though
congress has finally reached a deal to
provide
new economic relief for millions of
americans the 900 billion dollar package
includes help
for small businesses and a 600 dollar
check for most americans
that is less than democrats demanded but
more than most republicans wanted to
give
nancy cordes is following the
negotiations on capitol hill so nancy
how soon could this be approved vlad the
house and senate are hoping to pass this
bill
today even though most lawmakers haven't
even read it yet and the white house
says the president
looks forward to signing the bill
imminently after that the first stimulus
checks could start going out within the
next couple of weeks
and we now know more about exactly who
will get them
and who else stands to benefit from this
huge bill
i'm proud of the legislation it's a
first step
congressional leaders celebrated last
night after finally sealing the deal on
a relief bill
nine months in the making we can finally
report what our nation
has needed to hear for a very long time
more help is on the way the bill
contains another round of stimulus
checks for americans who make less than
seventy five thousand dollars a year
this time the payments will be six
hundred dollars for
every adult and dependent meaning a
family of four
will get twenty four hundred dollars
there's also
82 billion dollars for schools 57
billion for covid testing tracing and
vaccine distribution
more than 300 billion in loans and
grants for small businesses
45 billion for struggling transit
systems
13 billion to bolster snap and child
nutrition programs
and three hundred dollars in weekly
federal unemployment benefits
but just for the next two and a half
months might as well keep it
i don't you know i just don't see where
that's going to help at all
melinda shannon lost her job as a
restaurant manager in tampa in the
spring
at this point she says she's months
behind on rent
and about to lose her car we sold our
living room furniture
we sold all of our bicycles
chairs dining room set it's all gone
the bill does include 25 billion in
rental assistance
though the need is closer to 70 billion
it also extends the eviction moratorium
by a month
until january 31st so renters like
melinda can't be kicked out of their
homes
for now we must do more and when we come
back in january that will be job number
one
in a statement late last night
president-elect biden called this deal
just the beginning but he is going to
need the help of congress
if he wants to do another big relief
bill and since this one
took nearly a year to hash out doing
another round quickly could be very
challenging for him
if his party does not win back control
of the senate
in those runoffs in the senate in
january jamie
good point nancy thank you